[Music]
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
on Sunday we got the first official
trailer for Wonder Woman 1984 and it was
absolutely incredible Wonder Woman was
one of the most popular and successful
films that DC has put out in a very long
time and the sequel is looking to be
just the same but with the teaser
trailer came a ton of questions about
the movie the big one being how to Steve
Trevor who died in the last Wonder Woman
movie comeback for this film a lot of
people are wondering who exactly is
Kristin Wiggs character and who exactly
is the villain of this film well luckily
we know the answer to most of these
questions thanks to director patty
Jenkins actress gal gadot who of course
plays a Wonder Woman and actress Kristen
Wiig who plays cheetah so Kristin Wiggs
character that you see in the teaser
trailer for Wonder Woman 1984 is Barbara
Minerva and in the trailer it does seem
like the two of them become pretty good
friends they hit it off pretty well but
she's actually a classic a Wonder Woman
villain cheetah now although she is a
classic Wonder Woman villain from the
comics she's actually not going to be
the main villain of Wonder Woman 1984
that is actually going to be max Lord
played by Pedro Pascal and he's going to
be the true villain of Wonder Woman 1984
and he's also going to be responsible
for a cheetah and we'll talk about that
because we have a plot leak today now
this plot leaked actually came out
before the teaser trailer came out but
then the teaser trailer came out and it
actually lined up with a lot of what
happened so this plot leaked actually
seems very legitimate it is very very
detailed and it lines up with everything
that we saw in the teaser trailer so of
course with any plot league take it with
a grain of salt but just in case it ends
up being true spoiler alert as I
mentioned it does sound very legitimate
so if you do not want any spoilers for
Wonder Woman 1984 you should click away
now don't forget to subscribe with
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on all DC content and so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 this plot leak comes
from Twitter user viewer and on and it
starts off by saying
Wonder Woman 1984 kicks off in the
mascara as a young Diana Prince competes
Anna giant obstacle course of sorts
against much older Amazons now we
actually ended up seeing this in the
trailer we see a young dying
running next to a bunch of adult
Amazonian woman and then another scene
does show us some sort of an obstacle
course almost looks like their own
Olympic Games so this part of the leak
has already been confirmed to be true
just by the trailer being released but
the leak goes on to say it after making
her way across those columns Diana leaps
into the ocean below and then gets onto
a horse after washing ashore with a
decent lead the Amazon gets distracted
is knocked off her horse and ends up
cheating to a claim for his place
however just seconds away from victory
she's grabbed by anti Appiah then
lectures her on not taking the easy way
out we then moved to the 1980s and after
a quick montage featuring plenty of
1980s jokes and Wonder Woman's saving an
old woman from being knocked over we
visit a typical American mall where a
couple of gunmen are creating a
distraction while their fellow criminals
are in the back trying to get their
hands on some priceless artifacts the
titular hero then arrives saves the
little girl and takes down these goons
oh and yes she does indeed destroy the
security cameras in order to hide her
identity from the world and this is
something that we actually saw not too
long ago from leaked footage from Comic
Con and we also see this in the trailer
as well Barbara Minerva is quickly
introduced and it sounds like the sequel
goes all in on making it clear that
she's a loser no one seems to really
notice her no one cares when she drops
her things and even the cops who hired
her to investigate which artifacts were
stolen seemed to forget who she is
however there's one person who does
notice her Diana Prince at Diana's home
there are photos which shed some light
on what she's been up to all these years
and we get to see what became of some of
the characters from the first movie she
was a bridesmaid at Charlie's wedding
and is shown on a ship with an elderly
Etta candy checking in on Barbara diana
finds the doctor working with a strange
rock and everyone starts joking about
what properties it might have one guy
picks it up and wishes that he could
have a coffee right now and when he
walks away an intern walks in with extra
coffees everyone dismisses that as a
silly coincidence diana picks it up and
says she knows what she would wish for
and back in her apartment Steve Trevor's
watch suddenly springs to life after
some scenes with Diana and Barbara the
movie jumps to the next day where
Barbara is also shown mulling over what
she would wish for it turns out that she
would like to be as strong and sexy as
Diana and there are hints that this
comes true when her clubs
this is suddenly gone Maxwell Lord soon
makes his presence felt at the
Smithsonian and meets both Barbara and
Diana he invites them to a party he's
throwing and when he returns to his
office we learned that he's completely
broke
he's also determined to make his
eight-year-old son Alastair proud of him
Lord is also threatened by a man named
stag who wants out after yet another one
of his oil deals went wrong he's getting
desperate and seduces Barbara at the
party we learned why that is when he
spots that ancient stone and steals it
from behind her back while they kiss
diana chooses to go to the party and his
arrest by a guy who claims to know her
after repeating some lines from the
first movie she realizes that she's
talking to Steve Trevor and from this
point on both Wonder Woman and the
audience see him as Chris Pine despite
the fact that he's actually in a new
body they go for a walk and Steve
reveals that he remembers being on the
plane when it exploded and then waking
up in a bed in the 1980s there was
something in between but he doesn't know
what back in Lord's office we learned
that the villain knows exactly what the
artifact is and wishes to gain the
powers of the stone itself it turns to
dust and he is then imbued with
tremendous abilities meanwhile Steve and
Diana have grown close again and they go
to find him some new clothes they also
start investigating his return and after
coming face to face with the all-new
Barbara it's revealed that she knows
Lord has the stone and that she gave it
to him willingly
it's then revealed that when the stone
slashed Lord grants a wish it takes
something in return in the case of stag
he wishes that the wells would start
producing oil again but then ends up
being arrested for tax avoidance Lords
fortunes are turning around and when his
sole secretary wishes for more help a
number of people show up looking for a
job later on hundreds are shown trying
to get into his building
Diana and Steve break into Lord's office
and learn what he's done
they then sneak into a military base to
steal a plane for Steve to fly but
technology has advanced and they find
themselves being pursued believe it or
not though Diana has the power to make
things invisible and uses that on the
jet this is a scene that we actually saw
in the trailer we saw Steve and Diana in
a plane and although we did not see the
invisible jet in the trailer we have
seen it in leaked photos they then fly
through the fireworks and this is
something that we saw in the trailer as
well as all of this is happening Barbara
is starting to attack people Lord
meanwhile is making deals with foreign
leaders and grants I wish
magically erect a wall which will remove
the Cairo leaders enemies from his lands
however when he won't hand over his oil
reserves the villain takes his military
instead and decides to take the oil by
force this all ties into the cold war in
that massive action sequence with the
trucks from the trailers then plays out
as Diana attempts to get to Lord so she
can stop him once and for all however
Wonder Woman begins to notice that she's
vulnerable now and thinks she'd normally
shake off start to hurt her lord manages
to escape after she confronts him and
her weakened state means that two
children have very nearly died because
her powers are starting to fade this is
also affecting Lord as his body is
beginning to break down however his son
wishing that his dad can get everything
he wants gives him a boost and he
decides to meet with the US president
thanks to Barbara Steve and Diana
learned that using a wish means you have
to sacrifice something important to you
hence why the hero was starting to lose
her powers the only way to reclaim them
is to recant that wish but in Diana's
case that would mean saying goodbye to
Steve again killing Lord will do the
same thing and Barbara says she doesn't
want to lose her newfound confidence
Wonder Woman has been hiding her Golden
Eagle armor in her apartment and as its
forged from pieces of her fellow Amazons
armor it should help protect her during
what comes next in the White House Lord
grants the president's wish for nukes he
can use against Russia but requests his
power in return the villain also sees
some designs for a broadcast system he
believes can be used to grant wishes for
a huge amount of people at one time it's
then that Diana and Steve arrive and he
sets those security guards on the duo to
slow them down Barbara who now has
super-strength shows up to protect Lord
from Diana and proceeds to take her down
in a brutal fashion as they escape in
the president's helicopter he explains
that by granting wishes from all over
the world he'll take their health from
them so he can be rejuvenated Barbara in
the meantime wishes to become a true
apex predator transforming her into
cheetah war between America and Russia
is about to kick off thanks to what Lord
has been doing and Steve makes it clear
to Diana that she needs to sacrifice him
in order to save the world after an
emotional goodbye she leaps into action
Wonder Woman is back retrieving her
armor she goes after Lord who is now
broadcasting to the world chaos starts
ensuing everywhere but Lord is becoming
more and more powerful Wonder Woman is
then confronted by cheetah who is in
did a comic accurate Catwoman now so for
those of you who were wondering if she
is going to become part Sheeta according
to this leak she is it said that she's
either a white or very light gold she
stands up upright with her light fur
running down from her neck a tail and
sharp claws her hair's streaked black
and white and she has black marks on her
face like running mascara
Diana's armor is badly damaged during
their battle and after an intense fight
cheetah is electrocuted after refusing
to recant her wish the villain is still
alive but just barely and one woman then
heads off to confront Maxwell Lord but
now god-like villain is determined to
get more and more power and after a
brief fight and some taunts about Steve
Trevor it's revealed that Wonder Woman
has used the lasso of truth to broadcast
her words across the entire globe people
stop making wishes and after realizing
how much danger he's put his son in the
villain finally gives up his power
cheetah has been transformed back into a
human and as it turns out Lord Sun
wished for his father to come and find
him which is why he saw that he was in
trouble and decided to do the right
thing in the final few moments of the
film
Diana bumps into the man who Steve was
inhabiting and they wish each other a
Merry Christmas before going their
separate ways he has no memory of what
happened and during a voice-over Wonder
Woman talks about having faith in people
before going full Superman and leaping
into the air to answer a nearby alarm
and to once again save the day and that
is the entire Wonder Woman 1984 plot
leak and again many things that we heard
from this pot leak ended up being true
when we saw the teaser trailer so it's
likely that this is a very accurate plot
leak and it does all line up very well
with the comics everything makes perfect
sense
everything from Steve Trevor returning
to Maxwell Lord granting wishes and the
same goes for how Kristin Wiggs
character Barbara Minerva turns into
cheetah so this looks like it could be
what truly happens in Wonder Woman 1984
if this ends up being so what do you
think about this will you be happy with
a Wonder Woman 1984 playing out this way
it does sound like she's going to have
some pretty intense fights with cheetah
which is what I want but leave a comment
down below letting me know how you feel
about this and also don't forget to
subscribe when notifications turned on
and like the video so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or a ps4 the winner gets to choose don't
to use code cosmic at G fuel comm for
30% off G fuel and if you'd like a
chance to win an infinity gauntlet you
can click the link in the description
down below as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof